[Music]
one of the big
questions in modern physics is how do we
reconcile einstein's relativity with
quantum mechanics space-time itself is
not a continuous thing flat or curving
you can think of
ours the previous view of space time as
being this four-dimensional block of
stuff that comes equipped with slicings
into spaces at a time wouldn't it be
marvelous if we could
visualize extra dimensions wouldn't that
be fantastic what would it be like to
see extra dimensions
[Music]
the
greatest of the
british men
uh one of the two the other was william
shakespeare i suppose uh
sir sir isaac sir isaac newton
um has given us a extraordinary tool for
dealing with uh
with reality uh we still use neutron
equations for building bridges and
air plants and everything else
but especially has given us a vision of
what is real what this reality a way of
thinking about reality which in fact
it's the basis of his equation and which
is unbelievably simple and beautiful and
convincing and we all already sort of
have in our mind
which is the following there is a
huge empty space
right
uh which has no special direction up or
down all the same is the same all over
and so this is a this is sort of tablet
which is supposed to represent the space
so
it's equal and goes for lower for
infinity okay so that's the stage
and
on this stage uh time passes
for the space time time passes equal
since ever forever
and all the thing we see uh can just be
thought as bodies or particles move
around
and they move straight in space
forever
um until something uh pushes or pull
them forces newton forces and this
forces are generated by nothing else but
other particles
so that's it
um
space times and particles there are
curvature there's curvature space this
curvature can be so big that it could
you could make a hole and that's black
holes
and so on and so forth it's not just
space that curves have been cutting
short
the angles here a little bit is space
time
so it's not just
the extension space but the passage of
time which are bent what does this mean
well let me give you a simple
picture of that
so
uh
take a clock
and take another one
and they uh make sure they
indicate the same time they do
okay now lower one
keep it lower for a while
wait a moment then bring it up
look at them closely and if they're good
enough blocks these are not good enough
this is my grandfather but if these are
good enough clocks they don't indicate
the same time
the one who's been
lower is late with response the one that
has been
up which means the times go slower here
and and upper here
this is uh this is something and
einstein understood 100 years ago but
now it's not some strange idea finances
something which is verified in the
laboratory
pretty easily and regularly even a few
uh
half a meter of of
of
so time doesn't pass the same time
passes slower
down faster here if you think a moment
the reason the actual reason for which
things fall
okay they don't go straight they come
down
is because time passes a different speed
up here
than here so it's more convenient time
wise to go up and down rather than go
this way which if you think is the same
reason for which when you fly from
london to new york
and if you look at the map
you have a map of the earth right and
here's london here is new york and then
you look at what the airplane does it
does that
so why this stupid pilot goes always up
there well because the earth is round so
if you go to what if you're gonna want
to go from east to west
it's convenient to go north because the
distance between in west
meridians is smaller north
so this is actually shorter than this
the same reason for which this
is shorter than this space-time is
curved so it's convenient to go up and
down
rather than go straight
[Music]
the common sense view is that we don't
know what time is um and the common
sense view is is actually
what goes back to isaac newton and and
for many people who haven't taken a
course on relativity theory
we think we haven't progressed from
there so there's this cosmic clock that
ticks by the seconds the minutes the
hours at the same rate for everyone
uh and although we have our own own
subjective view of time that if if
you're enjoying this hour it'll go by
very quickly if you're bored you know
the time will will drag but you know
that so focus on the former focus on the
former absolutely
there's no danger
but we know that's our own subjective
view of time actually in 1905
einstein published his special theory of
relativity where he showed that that
view of time is wrong
time isn't an absolute it's not
something
abstract something that we have invented
or something that we have no control
over
time is
more tangible than that
it's tangible in the way that space is
tangible now in space we know we we have
access to three dimensions of space and
we can move forwards and backwards up
and down left and right
in time we are constrained
to moving in one direction
so we think in in certainly in physics
as time as having an arrow a direction i
remember one of my um
finest moments was when i was doing my
phd and i was looking up some some some
papers in the university library and i
came across one of stephen hawking's
papers so this is mid 80s
and where he talks about the arrows of
time the direction of time and how can
you define the direction of time is past
and future just something we've invented
um and actually
in this paper there are several
definitions of time and he then goes on
to point out that one way of defining
time is in the direction
in which the universe is expanding so
the past forget human memory what if
humans had never evolved what if there
was no life in the universe would there
still be time yes of course there will
be time it's part of the fabric of
what the universe is that
space-time as einstein calls it uh and
so hawking said well
if we define the direction of time as
going from the big bang onwards so the
big bang smaller universe is in the past
the direction of time is the direction
of the expansion of the universe
but if our psychological area of time
the way we think of part remembering the
past and looking to the future is in the
same direction as that
how would we know
if the universe is actually contracting
maybe the universe is getting smaller
that's because our arrow of time is
always pointing the direction of
expansion of time and
the first two or three pages of this
paper i followed and then he got into
the maths and stephen hawking's math
wasn't the same as my math it depends on
what area of physics you're in and i
lost him there but i was aware that he'd
made a mistake about the arrow of time
and i remember making some notes and
then remember a few years later reading
brief history of time where he conceded
he'd made a mistake and i remember
reading this on the train and smiling
grinning to myself that i i proved
somehow the stephen hawking had made a
mistake
but but it points to the fact that even
modern
physics doesn't really understand quite
how time fits into to our theories of of
the universe
relativity theory tells us that time can
be
squeezed and stretched there's no
absolute time time depends on the
observer if if two people are traveling
at
high speed relative to each other close
to the speed of light they will measure
time at flowing at different rates they
will see each other's clocks running
slower there is no absolute
present now
it depends on your frame of reference
and yet
the other great theory of modern physics
quantum mechanics
doesn't really describe time in in this
more complete way in quantum mechanics
time is just what's called a parameter
it's just
a way of
ensuring how things change cranking the
handle from past to future and and one
of the big
questions in modern physics is how do we
reconcile einstein's relativity with
quantum mechanics because until then we
won't have
a correct theory of time but we do know
a lot more about time than maybe some of
the philosophers might argue we do it is
much more than psychological time it's
much more than just how we care to
define it there's an absoluteness to
time
according to einstein that exists
whether or not humans care to
pontificate and philosophize about it
[Music]
now leibniz i think on one thing
i believe leibniz was right basically at
the most basic level on time
so
he he as space he said space is the
order of coexisting things and i replace
that by
space is the order of coexisting facts
and leibniz said
time is just the succession of
coexisting things and i would say the
succession of coexisting facts and it's
very easy to see what he meant by that
if i have a universe which just consists
of three particles i can imagine that in
one instant of time they look like that
and i want you only to think of the
shape that counts just the shape the two
angles determine the shape of of those
three particles there that that's that's
one there uh
and then i may be given i give one to
you then i give him the next one and
it's a different shape
but i could give you all intermediate
ones that go continuously one into the
other and just by the successive shapes
i could order them
in
in an order just using the information
in the successive shapes what i can't do
is put a direction onto it nothing in
that we know in physics actually puts a
direction on and says which one goes in
in which order but i think for
me the the leibniz is spot on that you
can really think of of the of the
universe as just being successive shapes
one after another like that and in fact
if i were to throw them down in a
confused heap there and shuffle them all
nothing is lost the information so it's
just like cutting up a movie into
individual stills
i can put them back in in the in the
right order
and if it's a proper movie telling a
proper story that we're familiar with it
will be a one direction in which you
play it we've all seen these reversed
films where people come out of swimming
pools backwards
the film was taken as they dive in and
then you just run the film backwards
but there is uh this is the problem of
the origin of the error of time
now i would say
i think there is a notion of now it is
just so to speak that the universe is
like this now that is our now
but
the universe is now different and this
is our now now
i don't i don't see einstein said he was
terrible the reason why einstein was
worried about there's no place for now
was because he denied a notion of
simultaneity but i think there is a
representation of einstein's theory
where you restore a notion of
simultaneity but you take out size and
you only look at shapes
so i think it will be possible to to
talk about now and i think einstein's
great concern about there being no place
for now in the modern world view is just
mistaken
uh it's always we are in a particular
now and it's it's constantly different
it's a wonderful world
[Music]
what we mean by becoming
or what we mean by to happen
is for something indefinite to become
definite
this is what we call an event
so einstein and special general
relativity like to talk about events
events for einstein
in classical physics non-quantum physics
are where two particles collide or
photon of light
is absorbed or emitted by a particle
that's an event for einstein
and what we're saying is that the events
are
notable because they wear something
indefinite to the position of the
electron
or the spin of the electron became
definite
we call that an event
only the becoming the transition
from indefinite to definite is real
so when i say real i mean fundamental
and real i mean present at the most
fundamental level of description
let me just read that again only the
becoming
the transition from indefinite to
definite
is real so we're saying
well you will see what we're saying
to exist is to trace a transitory event
and these transitions are what we call
now
the present and the fact that we
experience
the present and not the future and not
the past
is a consequence of this
to exist is to trace the transitory
event where something indefinite becomes
definite
hence everything that is real is real in
a particular moment the moment it
becomes definite
the present moment
and we may have events
which become
present which become definite together
so we call this the group of events
which in some sense
are present with respect to each other
or co-present the present moment
now these events exist
for some definite duration and that's a
long story you can ask me about
and then give rise to subsequent events
which makes up subsequent present
moments which again
exists for a finite duration and then to
cease to exist and give rise to the next
set
of moments of events
and this is how a world based only on
the distinction between indefinite
indefinite they define also causal
structure
causal structure is a word we physicists
love
it means what events cause white events
once an event that was indefinite
becomes definite you cannot reverse and
go back to becoming indefinite
once an event happens it cannot be made
to unhappen
there is a one-way
nature of reality the
events and the things become definite
that were indefinite other things become
definitely one definite and so on and so
forth
this makes the history of the world and
it's
got a big people worry about where does
the era of time come from that we
believe is where the hour of time comes
from
each event each becoming into
definiteness
happens for a reason these reasons come
from just prior events
and we want to get more specific energy
and momentum
are
real and part of the world and they're
passed on from event to event to event
so there's a kind of network of who
passed on so much energy to who
who passed it on to who passed on to who
and each moment
each of those events was real
the ones in the past will get to them
but no longer
no one's in the future no not yet
so the view of the pro now i talked
before about the view
of an event
and i've been talking for four or five
years about this the view of an event
is you think of what that event knows or
what it could know if it was a
somehow a sentient being
about the
causes that made it that is the
endowments of energy and momentum and
maybe other kinds of charges coming from
the events just to the past of it
and that
those views are the partial views that i
talked about at the beginning of what
the universe is composed of
there's a present moment things happen
they become definite
and the
structure of the world as it propagates
through time is the structure of who
caused who
who and whose energy endowed to his
energy
and if i'm sounding a bit um
wacky there's a whole
mathematical framework behind this
that we've developed with marina cortez
and others called energetic causal sets
but
i'm not presenting my job here is not to
present that but this is a kind of
interpretation
of that mathematics
the direction from indefinites
definitely gives the universe an error
of time events to narcosis
they have no past
apart from the endowments they inherit
and all that exists with definite
properties is the views of the events
in the present moment everything so the
world recreates itself in every moment
there's not a building here that's been
here forever this is a building that
every moment recreates itself
by the events of the last moment giving
rise to the events of the present moment
every structure every force every planet
every star
is continually recreating itself
everything we see around us exists or
did just exist there's god in the flesh
and life there's no need for a past
because the past can't affect us
there's nothing under our feet the past
is gone
[Music]
so i have this rather interesting
absolute structure mikowski space-time
it turns out
that all observers have to agree on
which events
uh
light from us can reach
and which events
uh
can emit light and reach us with that
light
so
this light cone structure picture the
following i suddenly sort of i have
something creates flashes of light and i
just flash and so they go out three
dimensions all around me i suddenly
flash light there's a whole set of
points that that light will reach
right i mean it's going to move very
fast but you know a tiny portion of a
second later it will reach the outside
of this room and then suppose it outside
this room is transparent it will
continue ongoing this is a whole set of
events that i can reach with a flash of
light and likewise there's a whole set
of events that right now light is
hitting me from
now
i haven't mentioned this but it also
follows from the structure of special
relativity that nothing can travel
faster than the speed of light right so
it turns out that there's this kind of
cone in space-time the inside of those
cones are all of the things that i can
actually affect or travel to and all the
things that can affect me or travel to
me so i do have this kind of useful
structure in microscopy spacetime but
what i don't have is a matter of fact
about how
amongst the events that
light which has a finite speed can't
reach me from light would have to travel
infinitely fast in some reference frame
to get to me from there i can't do that
um so
i can't really communicate with that
event and so there just isn't a matter
of facts according to special relativity
about whether that event is simultaneous
with me or not how i choose that slice
that hyper surface of simultaneity on
that diagram
how i choose that slicer whether i
choose to tilt it with light cone
depends on my reference frame
um one of the reasons why
that space-time formulation is so
helpful is that it makes it clear what
kinds of features should be relative to
a reference frame and what kind of
features should be absolute i'm going to
end up talking a bit about looking for
structures that are invariant with
respect to your reference frame and that
means things you and i can agree on even
if i'm on the moving train
so
generally different observers aren't
going to agree on how much time elapses
between two events because if you don't
don't agree on which things are
simultaneous you're not going to agree
on how much time elapses between two
events and your clocks can run
differently to mine and all of the rest
of it you're not going to really know
how far apart things are because your
rods are contracted relative to mine
but there are some things we'll agree on
it turns out there are some absolutes in
the space time and one of those things
is what you might think of as the
space-time distance between two points
you get the space-time distance by
squaring all distances and then naughty
subtracting a function of time says time
is a little bit different and then you
square root all of that and you get the
space-time distance
and actually it turns out that that
really simple little bit of mathematics
it's actually something we geometrically
call a metric
encodes all of the structure that's in
the light cone
so it turns out that if you have two
events in space time the light ray
could travel between
they must be though they're only a
lightweight travel between let's start
with this so you can have events that
are far enough apart that only something
moving at three times 78 meters per
second could get from one to the other
if they're like that then they're
light-like separated and the interval
between them uh is zero
slightly obvious this is a weird kind of
distance it turns out that things that
are separated by light rays count as
zero distance in my space time
events on the light cone
are light-like separated from the origin
event so all of those events that i can
reach with my flash of light are
light-like separated from me they have
zero space-time distance that's an odd
feature of this geometry um
if two events are such that something
traveling slower than the speed of light
so some material body
um could pass between them they're
time-like separated so the sequence of
events that i can reach by you know
going for a run
from um
from now are time like separated from me
and it turns out i can tell this i'm
like separated by calculating that
interval and if that interval is
negative and that distance is negative
it turns out it's time like separated
and likewise we can have events that are
space-like separated
so no material body could pass between
them but i could say send out a ruler to
connect them up
um
i have space like separate events and
the square of the interval between them
is positive and those are the events
that lie outside the light cone so if we
go back to looking at our light cone all
the events on the surface of the cone
are light like separated from me all the
events inside the cone are time-like
separated from me and all of these
things out here are space-like separated
and one of the consequences of special
relativity is that there's always a
reference frame which i can view any
space like separated event from me as
being simultaneous if i want to
[Music]
i want to
use this concept of color to introduce
the idea of a color space
this will allow us to
visualize what extra dimensions look
like and give us a new perspective on
many on some basic concepts that we know
we've learned in recent times
are at the foundation of how the
physical world works
local symmetry
okay so this is a picture
of what i showed you before different
way of representing the idea that we can
get
all the different colors as mixtures of
three this is called the color cube
and
along the different axes are different
intensities of
blue
green and red
okay if all of them are turned up
uh you get white
uh if you just go along this axis and
leave the other two zero you get pure
blue and so forth
and this represents if you could see the
interior look at it it would represent
all the different perceptive colors
every point inside the cube looks
different
and everything that
can be seen as a color is somewhere in
this cube so the space of colors makes a
three-dimensional space and the spaces
perceived colors makes a
three-dimensional space in this very uh
natural way
okay so
now uh
you may have heard
that
physicists like to think uh speculate
about their possibly being extra
dimensions additional spatial dimensions
uh and you may in your own life have to
deal with data sets that have many
different variables so it'd be nice to
be able to move in different dimensions
to rep to use different dimensions to
plot them all on a comment at the same
time uh
wouldn't it be marvelous if we could
visualize extra dimensions wouldn't that
be fantastic what would it be like to
see extra dimensions
well
let's think about what you look at what
you're seeing when you look at a
computer screen
or
what a computer is doing
when it's outputting some output but if
you had to program it and tell it what
it's got it's supposed to do
what would you need to do
well
you would have to tell on each pixel on
the screen so each x and y coordinate
at every time
which point on the color cube to display
which what
what the color of that perceived color
of that pixel should be
so
when you're looking at a computer screen
or when you're programming a computer
you're working in a six-dimensional
space-time
if you look at the numbers that describe
the situation
there's a time
there's a position
and there's the amount of red green and
blue inside the pro computer program
these are all very much on the same
footing they're just five different
numbers so
if you want to know what a five
dimensional space and a six dimensional
space time look like you're looking at
them
whenever you look at a
computer
screen
[Music]
matisse especially was at least
intuitively aware of this concept of a
color space
and in many many paintings played with
the idea of rotating different colors in
different places into one another
as you can see here
this anticipates
a kind of transformation
that's
fundamental
in modern physics called a local
symmetry transformation where you make
different kinds of transformations at
different places
so here uh matisse is using the concept
of local color symmetry uh that's that
really only entered physics in a big way
in the
third quarter of the 20th century
[Music]
there's pascal's triangle i i take it
most people have seen this at some time
or other and you can see that for
example the six in the middle is the sum
of the two threes above it and the three
is the sum of the one and the two above
it and so on
um
there's a somewhat less familiar wasn't
familiar to me structure which is a kind
of three-dimensional structure called
pascal square based pyramid but it works
just the same way i'm going to stack
stuff up
and put number a number the number one
at the top
and then just count
as it goes down
the number in each box will be the sum
of the numbers in the boxes above it
but now i'm stacking cubes on cubes
in such a way that each cube has four
cubes below it so it's easier to see it
right than to describe it you can see
that's what it looks like you've got a
one at the top
each of the four in the next layer the
four reds are all ones then you get the
next layer down and
you have ones in the corners twos in the
middle and four at the bottom and then
you can continue to go down
filling out
this pascal's pyramid
we can look at what it looks the fifth
level down these are what the numbers we
cut through it
horizontally and we looked at the fifth
level down these are the numbers now
if you just
kind of look at this
it has two really really interesting
important structures to it
one is that along the edges
those numbers are just the same ones you
got out of pascal's triangle so you've
got one four six four one along the
edges
and if we go back here you see one four
six four one
along pascal's triangle
and in the interior
you notice the whole thing looks like a
multiplication table so you get all the
numbers in the interior by just
multiplying the numbers the the
corresponding numbers of the edges so
you get the 24 by multiplying 4 and 6
and you get the 36 by multiplying 6 and
6 and so on
now we have a kind of fancy fact that
you just have to trust me on
which is that as you
go further and further down pascal's
triangle those that set of numbers so 1
4 6 4 1 and then 1 5 10 10 5 1 and so on
the structure of those numbers as you go
farther and farther down becomes closer
and closer to what's called a gaussian
normal distribution
which
is the function that i've written here f
of x
some normalization number e to the minus
one half x squared it has it's that bell
curve shape that everybody's familiar
with so
the numbers out of pascal's triangle are
not exactly that
but if you stay away from the far edges
they they become closer and closer to
being proportional to this distribution
this gaussian distribution
that's just a mathematical fact
now let's put those together
let's suppose we go many many many many
levels down
our pyramid
and we pick a point
somewhere in the center of the pyramid
not toward the edges
and we can say we can sort of
give it by its row and column x and y
only we're going to count x and y so
that the very middle is 0
plus 1 plus 2 plus 3 minus 1 minus 2
minus 3 and so on so every everything
will get a kind of address
that's a row and column
and
what will the path connectivity be
from the top
down to the point x1
well approximately now we're plugging in
my approximation here i'm plugging in my
gaussian distribution
and remember i just need to multiply the
there's i'll get a gaussian distribution
for x
and a gaussian distribution for y
and i multiply them together so you get
this equation at the bottom and it tells
you that the total number of paths
that go down to the point x y will be
approximately some number n squared
times e to the minus one half x squared
plus y squared that's our equation the
really important thing about that
equation if we go down to some level and
we cut through
horizontally at that level it tells us
that the path connectivity is
approximately proportional to x squared
plus y squared so if x squared plus y
squared equals x prime squared plus y
prime squared if they're about the same
number
then you have the same level of path
connectivity
but x squared plus y squared equals
constant is the equation for you could
encircle
that's the equation
so it tells you that
at the level of path connectivity in the
space time
[Music]
these euclidean circles naturally emerge
if the physics is sensitive to path
connectivity
even though the fundamental structure is
discrete and doesn't have
continuously any directions or anything
else the euclidean geometry will
naturally emerge
and so this gives me some hope to think
that this is a live possibility for how
to think about actual space time
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv